on partage ce constat mais vous êtes
bien vivant qu'est ce que ça vous fait
justement d'être vivant non de voir ce
film presque posthume de votre vivant un
jeu je me regrette je pense que j'étais
jeune j'étais pas mal c'est une telle
angoisse permanente quoi la mort n'ont
pas besoin non moi je vis une sorte de
vaudeville entre la vie et la mort sont
quand même dans les portraits rapport
esthétique à la mort je suis un
suicidaire qui s'attarde en effet oui
j'ai toujours pensé au suicide
j'y pense et j'ai dit non je pense à la
mort
et puis maintenant j'aurais sans doute
pas besoin de me suicider elle se
chargera de moi sans que je l'aide mais
je curieusement c'est la souffrance et
l'acharnement thérapeutique c'est tout
ça que je refuse
j'ai écrit un livre qui s'appelle le
jour et l'heure où le personnage d'une
certaine manière milite pour qu'ils
découvrent du d'appeler maintenant la
mort dans la dignité et j'appartiens
d'ailleurs à cette association vous êtes
engagés sur ce combat
oui et monsieur hollande a promis qu'il
ferait quelque chose pour nous mais
apparemment ça fait partie des promesses
non tenues vous vous comptez choisir le
jour et la wissant l'or avec ou sans la
permission du président de la république